[Música]
[Aplausos]
a música faz parte da vida de todo ser
humano
ela inicia a sua participação em nossas
vidas como ele estamos lá na página das
nossas mais depois disso faz algum tempo
ela participa das nossas vidas como as
nossas mães cantam para a gente para
acalmar o nosso favor temos depois na
escola quando nossos professores canto
com a gente depois em festas de amigos
aniversários com os familiares também
ela participe momentos trecho da vila
como por exemplo em uma guerra onde uma
tropa é conseguido através de toques
musicais e até mesmo a europa continuou
serra a nossa vida
a música está presente em todos os
eventos sociais mas
ia a música um papel importante nas
nossas vidas
apesar de ela estar presente sempre será
que a música ela tem poder de contribuir
positivamente nas nossas vidas nós somos
o projeto intermodal
sou professor josino professor anthony
professor fabrício e é sobre isso que
nós queremos falar com vocês hoje
mas para falarmos do percorrer ao mas
precisam se tornar um pouquinho primeiro
grau que ser percussão corporal e
percussão alternativa que é o que vocês
viram a gente fazer usar objetos
qualquer outra fonte tomara que não seja
o instrumento convencional dentro da
prática musical e no ano de 2012 quando
nós estávamos na faculdade
o sonho nada a tarefa de irmos até a
escola fazer um diagnóstico para ver as
possibilidades de realizar realizarmos
as aulas de música
vamos até lá o botão de lá uma das
coisas que mais nos incomodou é o fato
de não ter instrumentos musicais e nós
ainda estamos no início da faculdade que
nós vamos perguntar como faremos música
instrumentos
a gente até conseguir comprar alguma
possibilidade outra mais de forma a
realizar isso ea gente comum do que a
gente precisar pesquisar
e então saímos à pesquisa - saímos de
lages em santa catarina
fomos em diversas partes do brasil fazer
cursos estudar maneiras para solucionar
esse problema que nós encontramos ali
então tem uns cursos que nós fizemos com
o fernando barba do grupo barbatuques de
um grupo de percussão corporal é esse
curso dois anos lá cidade santa maria no
festival de música que acontece lá e ao
fazermos o curso estamos encantados com
aquilo promoção corporal se fazer música
com o corpo
acho que não existe forma mais
acessíveis fazer música que essa
além do aprendizado ser maior o seu uso
que o próprio corpo
você toca no próprio corpo para fazer a
música e voltamos lá encantados com isso
então começamos a realizar é oficina
como botamos pra lá em diversos eventos
semana de museus entre outros
devemos na cidade e foi incrível a o
pessoal estava muito feliz neste
trabalho ea percussão alternativa é se
encontramos através do pit stop
eles trabalham com materiais
alternativos com diversos objetos deus
vamos ea gente pensou a gente pode
agregar isso também para tornar a música
acessível a todos e então o processo foi
muito bom conseguimos realizar o nosso
trabalho durante o período da faculdade
como irmos a um ano de 2014 e no ano de
2015 nós tínhamos em mãos um artigo
relatando a as nossas experiências os
ótimos resultados que tivermos e
tínhamos também desejo muito grande
é hora de trabalho pois vários
professores falavam pra gente assim
vocês precisam levar isso adiante
e a gente começou a pensar mas
precisamos ir além da escola e em outros
lugares procurar lugares onde eles
também estão procurando a gente assim
como a gente não sabe deles eles também
não sabe da gente e nós precisamos nos
encontrar e foi aí que nós o projeto de
um novo mundo é nos novas faculdades nós
somos licenciados em música também somos
professores 63 atuam na educação assim
como o professor compartilha da mesma
idéia
a então a saída da faculdade a gente
tava possam de noiva no carro a fazer o
projeto acontecer mesmo então eram
escolas a mas não é fácil a nova projeto
né dentro da escola sem dó grande perigo
então um dia eu estava caminhando pela
rua passado passei na frente da
secretaria social
nenhum estava em pó
acho que aí começo a amiga e também
estava assim não sabia mail que mas eu
acho que aqui o caminho
conversamos é 60 anos fizemos um projeto
assistencial mas ainda bem inclusive não
sabemos nada sobre sensacional mas a
gente vai vendo algumas coisas ainda
assim um para levar a bom gosto bastante
e um pouco tempo depois do cras ea gente
pensou vavá não sabia que ela conhecia e
sabia quando falaram pra gente para
cuidar da beleza legal
crasso chocado a ideia do ponto do caso
chega no clássico ajuda deve explicar
pra gente é o seguinte pra significa
centro de referência em assistência
social é uma porta do suas sistema único
de assistência social
pra mim é o filtro para entrar nas suas
ali todos os programas sociais passam
pelo cras
você poderia imaginar o cras é a porta
de entrada
o jogador se cumprir o contrato com o
avançado é um lá eu contrário que eles
freqüentam justamente para disso nunca
ocorra né
e aí quando a gente ficou escolher seu
lugar porque a gente acredita
a gente não acredita em si na música por
música a gente como professor de música
a gente pensa que a música além disso a
ferramenta desa bom contrato e começamos
a trabalhar
é a gente trabalhou em várias escolas é
deus o teólogo várias histórias
periferia também desde muitos problemas
sabe mas o cras se concentram todos os
programas é um espaço é bem assim
e lá ele passou por várias dificuldades
assim é um projecto num não foi sempre
tudo legal 100% fácil a gente passou por
muitas dificuldades
a gente estava treinando na cabeça a
gente não conseguia explicar a matéria o
conteúdo ou passar o ritmo porque
simplesmente as crianças não eram sim
não se encaixava elas deus pelas ruas as
questões sociais que existe no bairro né
por crianças até mesmo tempo que é de
família serem parentes estarão inseridas
espaço e agora estamos fazendo juntos
a mesma música é no começo aconteceu com
acontecia né por vários momentos até a
gente até pensou marca não sei se vai
dar certo aí mas quando a gente começou
a conversar com eles ea gente entendeu
que realmente a música não é apenas
música a gente não queria formar músicos
de heliópolis se alguém quisesse devemos
aulas e ótimo nós a gente não entendeu o
nosso propósito era fazer a música
entender que eles tinham outras
oportunidades mesmo que não fosse da
música a a gente começou a fazer as
coisas se encaixaram
quando você entra em um balão de se a
gente toma agora uma criança
a primeira reação dele é bater o
adolescente mas não é a primeira reação
de seu instrumento
então quando eu entendo que esse
instrumento de trabalho para fazer
música pra vocês ouvirem pode ser um
instrumento a sondá-lo tese que a gente
achou que o governo pode ser instrumento
um ser humano pode ser o que quiser
então quando eles começam a entender
isso e aí tô começa a acontecer depois
da primeira apresentação apresentação na
forma do projeto mas quando acontece a
apresentação eles sobem no palco e eles
vêm de buck que eles podem conseguir
fosse descobre ver através da música ou
certeza a gente começa a parte várias e
aí sempre aquela história a gente não
pode só falar sobre música
fala sobre música sobre preconceitos
sobre religião sobre política muito
sobre política porque a gente precisa
falar sobre política política não por
despacho né ele sempre conversa muito
com eles nesse sentindo 100 e é isso a
us tocar junto à linha é fazê-los
entender que aquilo que lhe momento ali
30 crianças 30 adolescentes tocando ao
mesmo tempo junto não sai a sociedade
internet onde a claro isso aconteceu
porque várias pessoas estavam envolvidas
no processo uma música a música que
estou agora só aconteceu porque nós três
estamos envolvidos nesse processo se um
de nós aqui falhássemos com certeza nos
protestos que têm acontecido a mesma
coisa que a mesma coisa da nossa
sociedade
é por isso que a nossa sociedade está
bom está a gente é individualista é a
hora justamente do individualismo
a gente tem quando eles entendem que a
música une eles aqueles nomes que
brigavam lá que o pai a mãe de um deles
estavam vizinho lá eles ainda não gostam
a gente faz milagre mas a gente faz que
eles se respeitam e agora entendeu e aí
a música acaba sendo com o site
sociedade
e aí acontecem várias coisas espaço na
classe é um dia apresenta diversos
problemas como o relatar alguns aqui pra
vocês
no ano passado a gente está como casa da
cidade um lugar de periferia de bastante
problema social droga trabalho infantil
essa estrutura familiar
você deve imaginar o que mais a ideia
pode acontecer
a violência sexual nesse trace um grupo
de meninos que ela se juntado entre elas
la e resolveram que não queria ter
alguma quanto elas resolveram retornar
às aulas e não entrava gente
e assim foi durante algum tempo até que
chegou um momento que até 11 antônio dó
porque não dá mais pra não cair vou
conversar vou falar começou com as
orientadoras um casal
chamamos essas meninas que estavam
voltas na prova que está acontecendo e e
elas lá assinaram o termo de compromisso
que algumas desistiram outros acharam a
gente vai ter continuar por causa de
chegar em casa e dizer que ela foi
expulsa do caso no entanto é também
nosso papel é responsável mas também tem
que ter uma certa uma certa regra assim
vamos esperar que saíram e outros
resolveram a gente vai motivar beleza
continuar ea gente tem que depois uma
experiência
ruim né e começou a gente também
entender qualquer problema dessas dessas
meninas mais um dia a a coordenadora de
falar essas meninas elas têm problemas
quando é um professor homem professor
homem elas dêem a novo participar né
e no nosso estado mas ban ao ter uma
abordagem diferente então e foi
melhorando como a gente tem essa questão
de trabalhar muito protagonismo deles e
esse controle não venho sempre em forma
de apresentação musical que a gente
sempre falou tudo né organiza a chama a
comunidade chama os os pais e tios tal
deles e há um mês um álbum porque daqui
pra frente que faz aquela mudança desde
aqui e que não é só o galã que eles não
estão ali jogado muito na na periferia
que eles podem fazer a diferença
em uma delas a apresentação foi em
dezembro do ano passado estava tendo um
congresso dos servidores da saúde em
florianópolis e recebemos o convite para
o pecuarista presente fazer
a ação no congresso então olha só o 131
contexto é o congresso de trabalhadores
né
fonte ea epa filhos de trabalhadores
muitos trabalhadores desde empregados
mas também são trabalhadores e foram pra
esse congresso
muitos dos alunos que foram para lá
talvez seja a única oportunidade que
tiveram que conhecer o mar
espero que esteja errado mas para alguns
a linha pode ser por ter sido a única
oportunidade a gente foi feita a
apresentação
não vou aqui tá na cabeça de ninguém o
projeto é uma prática né
inclusive na cabeça professora aline e
seu esposo fizeram de fazer fizeram a
música que eles devem estrear durante
durante o ano todo e no final eles foram
ovacionados proporcionados mesmo assim
tipo mais de cinco minutos pessoal
aplaudiu de pé
e eles pegaram lá o seu instrumento para
dar uns instrumentos
o corredor assim no meio daquela galera
ovacionado mesmo e depois é claro net
vamos fazer um passeio na praia que foi
a má fase no olivais para conhecer o mar
é bem salgado mesmo água
o índice não sejam tivesse permanência
em de morte ea trégua porque não saíram
da gente saiu do ano de separar a água
são a salvar a mãe pobre sabe é que é
próprio jagger em quarto na primeira vez
mais se nela jean primeira vez na página
[Música]
um outro um outro que chamou a atenção
foi uma apresentação a gente fez o
universidade eo nosso lá se direcionando
o auditório sala onde agentes da música
um desvio onde eu vou estar lá
foi isso aí é a unidade fica gente como
professor né com
como ser humano a gente servir de
espelho uma sociedade né que tá lá a
margem na verdade a sociedade ea gente
serve de espelho e eles querem sinto
como a gente fazia diferença não é é
nesse sentido que o percurso ao zona de
procurar o hajj é o nome do coral quero
agradecer que deixar uma mensagem em que
diz que não existe de mais professores e
sim uma legião de aprendiz
[Música]
[Aplausos]